This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听TWO percent。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.|||在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.|||在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.|||迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《陷入爱河的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast,
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast,|||我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好，欢迎回到《二三十岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，
new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, let's talk about something that I don't think I have ever spoken about on the podcast before. Having kids, having babies, having children. It might seem so far off for some of us and so adult, but for other people, it is right around the corner. It is part of their future two, five, 10 year plan. And although I definitely think we've passed the days when we were kind of expected to have children by 22 or 23, it is definitely something that a lot of us start considering in our 20s, whether children are part of our future, whether maybe we want to be younger parents or whether we want to focus on our careers
new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, let's talk about something that I don't think I have ever spoken about on the podcast before. Having kids, having babies, having children. It might seem so far off for some of us and so adult, but for other people, it is right around the corner. It is part of their future two, five, 10 year plan. And although I definitely think we've passed the days when we were kind of expected to have children by 22 or 23, it is definitely something that a lot of us start considering in our 20s, whether children are part of our future, whether maybe we want to be younger parents or whether we want to focus on our careers|||新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然我们要剖析20多岁的心理学。今天，我们来聊一个我觉得以前在播客中从未谈论过的话题。生孩子，生宝，生小孩。对于我们中的有些人来说，这似乎还很遥远，显得非常成熟，但对其他人来说，这已经是迫在眉睫的事情了。这是他们未来两、五、十年计划的一部分。尽管我绝对认为我们已经过了那种仿佛必须在22或23岁生孩子的年代，但这绝对是我们许多人在20多岁时开始考虑的事情，思考孩子是否是我们未来的一部分，我们是否想早点当父母，或者我们是否想专注于职业生涯
and wait, regardless of your kind of preferences, regardless of what you want to do in your life. I do think that talking about children as a possibility, thinking about their role in our future is something that we really do need to start thinking about during this decade, as adult and mature as it seems. You know, I'm 24 at the moment, and I always, for the longest time, was convinced that I did not want kids. I didn't want a family of my own, especially when I was a teenager. I had these very huge exaggerated fantasies of, like, being the archetype of the fun, drunk, single art, traveling around the world, like, collecting, I was going to say, trophies, collecting trinkets, you know, this whole fabulous vision. And people would always tell me that I would change my mind.
and wait, regardless of your kind of preferences, regardless of what you want to do in your life. I do think that talking about children as a possibility, thinking about their role in our future is something that we really do need to start thinking about during this decade, as adult and mature as it seems. You know, I'm 24 at the moment, and I always, for the longest time, was convinced that I did not want kids. I didn't want a family of my own, especially when I was a teenager. I had these very huge exaggerated fantasies of, like, being the archetype of the fun, drunk, single art, traveling around the world, like, collecting, I was going to say, trophies, collecting trinkets, you know, this whole fabulous vision. And people would always tell me that I would change my mind.|||等等，无论你的喜好如何，无论你想在生活中做什么。我确实认为，将生孩子作为一种可能性来讨论，思考他们在我们未来扮演的角色，是我们在这个十年里确实需要开始思考的事情，尽管它看起来多么成年和成熟。你知道，我目前24岁，很长一段时间以来，我一直确信自己不想要孩子。我不想要自己的家庭，特别是当我还是个青少年的时候。我有一些非常巨大且夸张的幻想，比如成为那种有趣、酗酒、单身的艺术家的典范，周游世界，收集——本想说奖杯——收集小饰品，你知道的，那种美妙的愿景。人们总是告诉我，我会改变主意的。
I really resented that. I honestly still don't believe that everybody does change their mind. But let me tell you something. I turned 23 and it was like suddenly I was sure and I was sure that I wanted children and it was like something had clicked in my brain that I wanted to be a mum done, you know, a mom someday and it really startled me and for the first time it really had me considering things like parenting, things like fertility and it brought a new lens to my health and who I was dating. And of course, when that happened, I turned to my friends about it because that is my main source of wisdom and so many of them had experienced something similar. Some of my friends who had always been very, you know, firm in their decision that they did not
I really resented that. I honestly still don't believe that everybody does change their mind. Let me tell you something. I turned 23 and it was like suddenly I was sure and I was sure that I wanted children and it was like something had clicked in my brain that I wanted to be a mum done, you know, a mom someday and it really startled me and for the first time it really had me considering things like parenting, things like fertility and it brought a new lens to my health and who I was dating. And of course, when that happened, I turned to my friends about it because that is my main source of wisdom and so many of them had experienced something similar. Some of my friends who had always been very, you know, firm in their decision that they did not|||我对此感到非常反感。老实说，我仍然不相信每个人都会改变主意。我告诉你一件事。我23岁生日那天，就好像突然之间我很确定了，我确凿地想要孩子，就好像我脑子里的某个开关被打开了，我想要成为一个妈妈，你知道的，总有一天要当妈妈，这真的吓到我了。这是我第一次真正开始考虑诸如育儿、生育之类的事情，它为我的健康以及我的约会对象带来了新的视角。当然，当这一切发生时，我向我的朋友们倾诉，因为那是我主要的智慧来源，而且她们当中有很多人都经历过类似的经历。我的一些朋友一直以来都非常坚定地决定他们不
want children, they remained firm. Others like me had like shifted entirely and, you know, it's like I turned 24 and suddenly I've had more conversations about egg freezing than I have ever had before and so many people are talking to me about fertility or starting to really care that their period is consistent or about what they're eating and their health and I want to talk about it when do we really need to start thinking about kids do we need to start thinking about it in our 20s or at all what are the factors that we need to consider what about when it comes to our romantic life the pressure to find somebody is it all too adult too soon and should we kind of preserve our youth for as long as possible.
want children, they remained firm. Others like me had like shifted entirely and, you know, it's like I turned 24 and suddenly I've had more conversations about egg freezing than I have ever had before and so many people are talking to me about fertility or starting to really care that their period is consistent or about what they're eating and their health and I want to talk about it when do we really need to start thinking about kids do we need to start thinking about it in our 20s or at all what are the factors that we need to consider what about when it comes to our romantic life the pressure to find somebody is it all too adult too soon and should we kind of preserve our youth for as long as possible.|||想要孩子，她们依然立场坚定。其他人像我一样发生了彻底的转变，你知道的，就像我24岁了，突然间我关于冷冻卵子的讨论比以往任何时候都多，很多人跟我谈论生育能力，或者开始真正关心自己的经期是否规律，或者关心自己的饮食和健康，我想谈谈这个：我们究竟什么时候才真正需要开始考虑孩子？我们是在20岁的时候开始考虑，还是根本不需要？我们需要考虑哪些因素？当我们谈到浪漫生活时，找到某人的压力呢？这一切是不是来得太早太成熟了，我们是否应该尽可能长时间地保留我们的青春？
You know, there are so many questions that come up around this. And it's so easy to kind of just like put it off. I'm going to make the argument for why thinking about it is actually going to give you more freedom and more choice than not thinking about it. And we also heard from a few listeners who have children who are expecting in their 20s about how they knew when they were ready and what we can learn from their experiences when it comes to family and future planning. So without further ado, it's a much different episode today,
You know, there are so many questions that come up around this. And it's so easy to kind of just like put it off. I'm going to make the argument for why thinking about it is actually going to give you more freedom and more choice than not thinking about it. And we also heard from a few listeners who have children who are expecting in their 20s about how they knew when they were ready and what we can learn from their experiences when it comes to family and future planning. So without further ado, it's a much different episode today,|||你知道，围绕这个话题会出现这么多的问题。而且人们很容易就这样把事情搁置一旁。我将在这里论证，为什么思考这个问题实际上会比不去想它给你带来更多的自由和选择。我们还听取了几位20多岁就已经有孩子或正期待孩子的听众的意见，了解他们是如何知道自己已经准备好的，以及在家庭和未来规划方面我们可以从他们的经验中学到什么。废话不多说，今天这一集非常不同，
but one that I am so excited about. Let's get into it. Having children is such a distinctively adult conversation, regardless of where you are at in your 20s. It is still so shocking to hear from my friends in their late 20s or early 30s that they're expecting children. Because it's kind of like you've hit a strange fork in the road, like an intersection of sorts,
but one that I am so excited about. Let's get into it. Having children is such a distinctively adult conversation, regardless of where you are at in your 20s. It is still so shocking to hear from my friends in their late 20s or early 30s that they're expecting children. Because it's kind of like you've hit a strange fork in the road, like an intersection of sorts,|||但我对此感到非常兴奋。让我们切入正题吧。生孩子是一个绝对属于成年人的话题，无论你处于20多岁的哪个阶段。听到20多岁末或30多岁初的朋友说他们要生孩子了，依然是一件非常震撼的事。因为这就好像你来到了一个奇怪的十字路口，某种意义上的交叉口，
People's life paths split and children and I think also, you know, marriage to some extent, but that like is where the split occurs. Some of us are still getting super drunk on the weekends. Some of us don't have a dollar in savings, but there are other people posting, you know, engagement announcements or getting IVF or going to OBGYN appointments. Everyone's path is super different. But I think for many of us, we are in a few minds when it comes to whether it's even, you know, the time to consider whether kids are part of the plan, let alone start trying to have kids. If we aren't sure, do we need to decide now?
People's life paths split and children and I think also, you0 know, marriage to some extent, but that like is where the split occurs. Some of us are still getting super drunk on the weekends. Some of us don't have a dollar in savings, but there are other people posting, you know, engagement announcements or getting IVF or going to OBGYN appointments. Everyone's path is super different. But I think for many of us, we are in a few minds when it comes to whether it's even, you know, the time to consider whether kids are part of the plan, let alone start trying to have kids. If we aren't sure, do we need to decide now?|||人们的生活轨迹分叉了，孩子，还有我认为在某种程度上也包括婚姻，但分叉就是从那里发生的。我们中的一些人在周末仍然喝得酩酊大醉。我们中的一些人连一美元的存款都没有，但还有人在发布订婚公告、做试管婴儿（IVF）或去看妇产科医生。每个人的道路都大不相同。但我认为对我们中的许多人来说，当谈到是否是时候考虑孩子是否是计划的一部分时，我们都心存疑虑，更不用说开始尝试要孩子了。如果我们不确定，我们现在必须做出决定吗？
Or can we, you know, it kind of feels like even thinking about it pops the bubble a little bit. It pops the bubble of being carefree and young. Because once you do start considering it, some really big things come up. you know, especially not just in terms of like, do you want to start considering whether you should have kids now? It's even the question of like, do I want to consider whether I want kids at all and when I might want to start? What comes up with that is questions around like ethics and climate change and recession and like the world that we would be bringing children into. And it's almost like once you are like, yeah, maybe I do want children. Is that when you have to start.
Or can we, you know, it kind of feels like even thinking about it pops the bubble a little bit. It pops the bubble of being carefree and young. Because once you do start considering it, some really big things come up. you know, especially not just in terms of like, do you want to start considering whether you should have kids now? It's even the question of like, do I want to consider whether I want kids at all and when I might want to start? What comes up with that is questions around like ethics and climate change and recession and like the world that we would be bringing children into. And it's almost like once you are like, yeah, maybe I do want children. Is that when you have to start.|||还是我们可以，你知道的，就感觉仅仅是去思考它就会戳破一点泡沫。戳破了无忧无虑、年轻无畏的泡沫。因为一旦你开始认真考虑，一些非常重要的事情就会浮出水面。你知道的，这不仅仅是“你现在是否想开始考虑要不要孩子”的问题。这甚至关乎“我是否想考虑自己到底要不要孩子，以及我可能想在什么时候开始”的问题。随之而来的是诸如伦理道德、气候变化、经济衰退以及我们将把孩子带入一个什么样的世界之类的问题。这几乎就像是一旦你觉得“好吧，也许我确实想要孩子”，难道那就是你必须开始……
making a plan, is that when we kind of start to feel strapped to a timeline? Because once we start thinking about kids, there is this acknowledgement that there is a bit of a to-do list that comes with that. You know, you have to find a suitable partner or most people would prefer to have a partner with them to raise a child. You have to kind of get your finances sorted, get your life sorted before a window closes. And for women, obviously, that window is our biological clock. And, you know, typically I really hate that phrase because it very much connotes that like when the clock hits zero we expire or we are past our worth that we've run out of time you know as if our lives don't continue whether we have children or not but that is what we know it as colloquially and we also know that there is like a deadline for
making a plan, is that when we kind of start to feel strapped to a timeline? Because once we start thinking about kids, there is this acknowledgement that there is a bit of a to-do list that comes with that. You know, you have to find a suitable partner or most people would prefer to have a partner with them to raise a child. You have to kind of get your finances sorted, get your life sorted before a window closes. And for women, obviously, that window is our biological clock. And, you know, typically I really hate that phrase because it very much connotes that like when the clock hits zero we expire or we are past our worth that we've run out of time you know as if our lives don't continue whether we have children or not but that is what we know it as colloquially and we also know that there is like a deadline for|||制定计划的时候吗？难道那就是我们开始感到被时间表束缚的时候吗？因为一旦我们开始考虑孩子，就会意识到随之而来的是一张待办事项清单。你知道的，你必须找到一个合适的伴侣，或者大多数人更愿意有个伴侣陪自己抚养孩子。在某个窗口关闭之前，你得把财务理清，把生活理顺。对女性来说，显而易见，那个窗口就是我们的生物钟。而且，你知道的，通常我真的很讨厌这个词，因为它强烈暗示着当钟表归零时我们就过期了，或者我们已经失去了价值，我们的时间用光了，你知道的，就好像无论我们是否有孩子，我们的生活都不会继续下去一样，但这就是我们日常所知的说法，我们也知道存在着一个关于……的最后期限。
reproduction not to make it sound so clinical but around you know 30 to 35 our ability to have children declines and it continues on that kind of plane it continues to decline before menopause so knowing that does that change how we live our 20s even if we don't want to start having kids to our 30s knowing that it might be more difficult and the thing that I often hear from people is like if children are a certainty in my life plan why not do it in my 20s because there is a great chance that I can have children naturally. There's a greater chance that I'll be around longer and I might have more of that support system in my parents, in my grandparents, even, you know, some of us are so lucky to still have, you know, both sets of grandparents alive. I can bounce back
reproduction not to make it sound so clinical but around you know 30 to 35 our ability to have children declines and it continues on that kind of plane it continues to decline before menopause so knowing that does that change how we live our 20s even if we don't want to start having kids to our 30s knowing that it might be more difficult and the thing that I often hear from people is like if children are a certainty in my life plan why not do it in my 20s because there is a great chance that I can have children naturally. There's a greater chance that I'll be around longer and I might have more of that support system in my parents, in my grandparents, even, you know, some of us are so lucky to still have, you know, both sets of grandparents alive. I can bounce back|||生育的最后期限——为了不让它听起来那么冷冰冰——但在你知道的30到35岁左右，我们生育孩子的能力会下降，并且会沿着那种水平面继续下降，在更年期到来之前会持续下降，所以知道了这一点，会改变我们度过20多岁的方式吗？即使我们不想在30岁之前开始生孩子，明知那可能会更困难。我经常从人们那里听到的一句话是：如果孩子是我人生计划中笃定的部分，为什么不在20多岁时生呢？因为我能自然生育的几率很高。我陪伴孩子的时间会更长，而且我在父母、祖父母那里可能会有更多的支持系统，甚至，你知道的，我们中的一些人非常幸运，两边的祖父母都还健在。我可以更容易地从……中恢复过来
from a career break easier. Like there are a lot of pros, but there are also a lot of cons, right? the loss of freedom, the quick change in life trajectory compared to all of our friends, the money, that's a huge one, the money. Children are so expensive. But also, it's this like capacity and this lifestyle that we would be giving up. So that I think is the thing that really contributes to the decision to have kids in our 20s or to even consider it. Because even if you do want to have kids eventually in your 30s, there is kind of an acknowledgement that there is a chapter that will close when that decision is made. And of course there is a chapter for everything, but I think the chapter that you are in without children is one of immense freedom. It's being able to go out
from a career break easier. Like there are a lot of pros, but there are also a lot of cons, right? the loss of freedom, the quick change in life trajectory compared to all of our friends, the money, that's a huge one, the money. Children are so expensive. But also, it's this like capacity and this lifestyle that we would be giving up. So that I think is the thing that really contributes to the decision to have kids in our 20s or to even consider it. Because even if you do want to have kids eventually in your 30s, there is kind of an acknowledgement that there is a chapter that will close when that decision is made. And of course there is a chapter for everything, but I think the chapter that you are in without children is one of immense freedom. It's being able to go out|||职业中断中恢复过来。有很多优点，但也有很多缺点，对吧？失去了自由，与我们所有的朋友相比生活轨迹发生了迅速的变化，金钱，这是一个巨大的问题，金钱。养孩子太贵了。但同时，这也是我们要放弃的这种能力和这种生活方式。所以我想这才是真正促成我们在20多岁时决定要孩子或甚至考虑要孩子的因素。因为即使你确实想在30多岁时要孩子，大家也多少有一种共识，那就是一旦做出那个决定，就会有一个章节宣告结束。当然，凡事都有其对应的篇章，但我认为没有孩子的这个阶段充满了无限的自由。你可以随时随地……
for drinks or out for dinner with your friends any night of the week. It's, you know, coming home when you feel like it. It is having the freedom to travel where and when you would like. It is having the freedom to sleep in or, you know, to just actually be in control of your life. And there is a brief window where we truly get that after we turn 18 to when we might, you know, have kids. Obviously, if you don't end up having kids, you literally, you win the lot of you. You get to have that freedom for the rest of your life. Congratulations. But, you know, if you want to have kids at some point, like you're likely going to want to start trying before you're like 40. So that's like 22 years to like get it all out of your system, to travel where you want,
for drinks or out for dinner with your friends any night of the week. It's, you know, coming home when you feel like it. It is having the freedom to travel where and when you would like. It is having the freedom to sleep in or, you know, to just actually be in control of your life. And there is a brief window where we truly get that after we turn 18 to when we might, you know, have kids. Obviously, if you don't end up having kids, you literally, you win the lot of you. You get to have that freedom for the rest of your life. Congratulations. But, you know, if you want to have kids at some point, like you're likely going to want to start trying before you're like 40. So that's like 22 years to like get it all out of your system, to travel where you want,|||在每周的任何一个晚上出去和朋友喝酒或吃晚饭。你知道的，想几点回家就几点回家。拥有随时随地想去哪旅行就去哪旅行的自由。拥有睡懒觉的自由，或者说，真正掌控自己生活的自由。在我们年满18岁到我们可能要生孩子的那段时间之间，有一个短暂的窗口期，让我们真正拥有这一切。很显然，如果你最后没有生孩子，简直就像是中了彩票。你的余生都能拥有那种自由。恭喜你。但是，你知道的，如果你在某个时刻想要孩子，你很可能会在40岁之前就开始尝试。所以大约有22年的时间可以让你尽情挥洒，去你想去的地方旅行，
to do what you want, like maybe max. You might want to start trying early. You might not want to have like a geriatric pregnancy. When you like, I'm obviously spiraling here, but it's the case that when you start thinking about it, you start thinking about how much this decision might impact other areas of your life. If it's not just around like, yeah, I want to have a baby. It's work decisions. Will you be able to have a career break?
to do what you want, like maybe max. You might want to start trying early. You might not want to have like a geriatric pregnancy. When you like, I'm obviously spiraling here, but it's the case that when you start thinking about it, you start thinking about how much this decision might impact other areas of your life. If it's not just around like, yeah, I want to have a baby. It's work decisions. Will you be able to have a career break?|||做你想做的事，大概最多也就这样了。你可能想早点开始尝试。你可能不想经历高龄产妇。当你像我一样——我在这里显然有点思维失控了——但事实是，当你开始思考这个问题时，你就会开始思考这个决定可能会对你生活的其他领域产生多大影响。如果它不仅仅是围绕着“是的，我想生个孩子”。还有工作上的决定。你能获得职业中断吗？
Do you want to climb the corporate ladder or not? It's travel plans. Do I want to... Are there places that I wouldn't be able to go with kids that I want to go now? Are there experiences that I want to have that I know are going to become more difficult? Like solo traveling, you obviously can't solo travel if you have a baby. Because the baby's got to be there. Big factor.
Do you want to climb the corporate ladder or not? It's travel plans. Do I want to... Are there places that I wouldn't be able to go with kids that I want to go now? Are there experiences that I want to have that I know are going to become more difficult? Like solo traveling, you obviously can't solo travel if you have a baby. Because the baby's got to be there. Big factor.|||你想在职场上往上爬吗？还有旅行计划。我想……有没有什么地方是我现在想去，但有了孩子就去不了的？有没有什么我想拥有的体验，我知道以后会变得更加困难的？比如独自旅行，如果你有了宝宝，显然就不能独自旅行了。因为宝宝必须得在身边。这是个巨大的影响因素。
And then dating, dating. Do you, like, how serious are you going to get? How quickly? And I think that when you have this acknowledgement of like, okay, no, eventually I do want kids and I know that it might be easier to try. Like, in my late 20s or my early 30s, it might put a lot more pressure on the people that you are romantically interested in. So I was speaking to a friend about this very component the other day. And obviously we are, you know, in a day and age where it's not like a man and woman need to like get together at 22 and have babies by 25 otherwise. Like that's it.
And then dating, dating. Do you, like, how serious are you going to get? How quickly? And I think that when you have this acknowledgement of like, okay, no, eventually I do want kids and I know that it might be easier to try. Like, in my late 20s or my early 30s, it might put a lot more pressure on the people that you are romantically interested in. So I was speaking to a friend about this very component the other day. And obviously we are, you know, in a day and age where it's not like a man and woman need to like get together at 22 and have babies by 25 otherwise. Like that's it.|||然后是约会，约会。你，比如说，你会有多认真？有多快？我认为，当你有了这种认知，即“好吧，不，最终我确实想要孩子，而且我知道趁早尝试可能会更容易”，比如在20多岁末或30多岁初，这可能会给你对其产生浪漫兴趣的人带来更大的压力。所以前几天我正在和一个朋友谈论这个具体的要素。很显然，我们处在一个这样的时代，男女不必非得在22岁聚在一起，在25岁前生孩子，否则就完了。
You're not going to reproduce. There are so many other options. There is IVF. There is adoption. There is surrogacy. So many things. But, you know, sometimes the dream is to have somebody to do it all with, to have a partner to help raise your child, especially. a partner that we love that can feel so special.
You're not going to reproduce. There are so many other options. There is IVF. There is adoption. There is surrogacy. So many things. But, you know, sometimes the dream is to have somebody to do it all with, to have a partner to help raise your child, especially. a partner that we love that can feel so special.|||你将无法繁衍后代。还有很多其他的选择。有试管婴儿。有收养。有代孕。有太多的事情。但是，你知道的，有时梦想是能有一个人与你共同经历这一切，特别是有一个伴侣来帮你抚养孩子。一个我们深爱的伴侣会让人感觉如此特别。
But it also ups the stakes if you haven't already kind of found that person and you're getting older. You're not just facing the stigma of a society that puts romantic love on a pedestal and pity singleness, but it's also really confronting to realize that the key to unlocking your life plan rests in a stranger that you're yet to meet. And it's kind of like, how do you rush something that isn't always up to you? how do you tick this off your list to make it sound super, super clinical? And I was speaking to a friend about that and how she is now in her kind of like early 30s and how
But it also ups the stakes if you haven't already kind of found that person and you're getting older. You're not just facing the stigma of a society that puts romantic love on a pedestal and pity singleness, but it's also really confronting to realize that the key to unlocking your life plan rests in a stranger that you're yet to meet. And it's kind of like, how do you rush something that isn't always up to you? how do you tick this off your list to make it sound super, super clinical? And I was speaking to a friend about that and how she is now in her kind of like early 30s and how|||但如果你还没有找到那个人并且正在变老，这也提高了赌注。你不仅要面对一个将浪漫爱情奉上神坛、对单身投以同情目光的社会的污名化，而且真正面对这样一个事实也让人备受打击：开启你人生计划的钥匙竟然掌握在一个你尚未遇见的陌生人手中。这就有点像，你如何去催促一件并不总是由你说了算的事情呢？你如何从你的清单上勾掉这个项目，让它听起来超级、超级冷血？我曾和一个朋友谈过这件事，谈到她现在处于30岁出头左右的年纪，以及
stressful it is, that it's no longer just about finding a connection. Because yes, of course, that obviously is the most important thing. But it's also about making sure that you're on the same page. She said to me, she was like, when I decided that yes, I did want kids, it wasn't about that I wanted kids in my 20s, I just wanted them eventually. Everything else became a lot more serious. And she was like, I realized that I'm getting to an age where I don't have the luxury of getting to know you.
stressful it is, that it's no longer just about finding a connection. Because yes, of course, that obviously is the most important thing. But it's also about making sure that you're on the same page. She said to me, she was like, when I decided that yes, I did want kids, it wasn't about that I wanted kids in my 20s, I just wanted them eventually. Everything else became a lot more serious. And she was like, I realized that I'm getting to an age where I don't have the luxury of getting to know you.|||这有多么压力山大，因为这不再仅仅是关于找到心灵契合。因为是的，当然，这显然是最重要的。但这也是为了确保你们的想法合拍。她对我说，她说，当我决定“是的，我确实想要孩子”时，并不是说我想在20多岁要孩子，我只是最终想要它们。其他一切都变得更加严肃了。她接着说，我意识到我到了这样一个年龄，我没有那种奢侈的时间去慢慢了解你。
Like, I don't have the luxury of like, let's figure it out. It was like, no, if I'm going to spend a year dating you or a couple of years, I want to know that we are on the same page about kids or about family, about values. and the timeline for things really shifts. Not that you are rushing it. Hopefully you are not rushing it. But it's more that there is a directness and an intentionality. And it's more like you have to make calls about big things like kids earlier on
Like, I don't have the luxury of like, let's figure it out. It was like, no, if I'm going to spend a year dating you or a couple of years, I want to know that we are on the same page about kids or about family, about values. and the timeline for things really shifts. Not that you are rushing it. Hopefully you are not rushing it. But it's more that there is a directness and an intentionality. And it's more like you have to make calls about big things like kids earlier on|||就像，我没有那种“让我们慢慢摸索吧”的奢侈。这就变成：不，如果我要花一年或几年的时间跟你约会，我想知道我们在孩子、家庭、价值观上是否意见一致。事情的时间线真的发生了转变。倒不是说你在催促它。希望你没有在催促它。而是更多了一种直白和刻意。更像是你必须更早地对孩子这样的大事做出决定
and make sure that you're on the same page. And when you're 19 or 22, you know, you kind of have time to have your doubts. You can date people that you probably don't think is going to be the one. and it's not going to really hurt your long-term chances of creating the dream life with the kids or without the kids. You can have those kind of fairy tale conversations about the future without needing to enact plans right away, but that changes the order you get. And it definitely is probably going to give you a fairly large dose of milestone anxiety. If you kind of wake up to the conclusion that children are part of your life plan
and make sure that you're on the same page. And when you're 19 or 22, you know, you kind of have time to have your doubts. You can date people that you probably don't think is going to be the one. and it's not going to really hurt your long-term chances of creating the dream life with the kids or without the kids. You can have those kind of fairy tale conversations about the future without needing to enact plans right away, but that changes the order you get. And it definitely is probably going to give you a fairly large dose of milestone anxiety. If you kind of wake up to the conclusion that children are part of your life plan|||并确保你们的想法是一致的。当你是19岁或22岁时，你知道的，你多少有时间去心存疑虑。你可以和那些你可能觉得不是真命天子的人约会。这不会真正损害你长期以来创造有孩子或没有孩子的理想生活的机会。你可以进行那种关于未来的童话般的对话，而无需立即实施计划，但这会改变你获得这一切的顺序。如果你突然意识到孩子是你人生计划的一部分，这肯定会给你带来相当大剂量的里程碑焦虑。
and that part of getting there is finding somebody and you haven't done that yet. and the reason I say milestone anxiety specifically is because that really derives from a sense that you are not where you want to be in life or where you should be. It can still feel like there is this key ingredient that you are missing. And although milestone anxiety is typically applied to things like career or financial goals, when it does come to relationships, I think it's a lot more complicated because it's not like there is a formula for success or a correlation between FAA. and output. It is so influenced by things like chance and timing. And if you believe in it, fate. So I think it's really hard to not feel in control of something so significant for the life you dream of. And even when I think everything goes according to plan, right, even if you are, you know, you've assessed your emotional preparedness, you've assessed your financial preparedness,
and that part of getting there is finding somebody and you haven't done that yet. and the reason I say milestone anxiety specifically is because that really derives from a sense that you are not where you want to be in life or where you should be. It can still feel like there is this key ingredient that you are missing. And although milestone anxiety is typically applied to things like career or financial goals, when it does come to relationships, I think it's a lot more complicated because it's not like there is a formula for success or a correlation between FAA. and output. It is so influenced by things like chance and timing. And if you believe in it, fate. So I think it's really hard to not feel in control of something so significant for the life you dream of. And even when I think everything goes according to plan, right, even if you are, you know, you've assessed your emotional preparedness, you've assessed your financial preparedness,|||而实现这一目标的一部分是找到某人，而你还没做到这一点。我之所以特指里程碑焦虑，是因为这确实源于一种感觉：你没有处于你希望的生活位置，也没有处于你应该在的位置。你仍然会觉得你缺少了这样一个关键要素。尽管里程碑焦虑通常适用于职业或财务目标之类的事情，但当涉及到感情关系时，我认为事情要复杂得多，因为这不像是有成功的公式，或者投入与产出之间有什么关联。它受机遇和时机等因素的影响太大了。如果你相信的话，还有命运。所以我认为，对于你梦想的生活中如此重要的事情，很难不感到失去控制。即使我认为一切都按计划进行，对吧，即使你是，你知道的，你已经评估了你的情感准备，你已经评估了你的财务准备，
your social preparedness, the strength of your relationship, you are in a relationship, you're both ready to have kids, you know, and you've been like, yeah, I'm going to start in my 20s. I'm going to, this is what I want, I want to be a younger parent. This is just what feels right for me. Sometimes it doesn't always work out the way that we want it. You can be absolutely sure of your decision and life can still throw you curveballs. And a big one that I think a lot of us in our early 20s in particular don't think about is fertility, not just like the biological clock, but also kind of, I whether we're able to even have kids, the state of all those other systems. This is just not something that we think about when we are 20 or 21.
your social preparedness, the strength of your relationship, you are in a relationship, you're both ready to have kids, you know, and you've been like, yeah, I'm going to start in my 20s. I'm going to, this is what I want, I want to be a younger parent. This is just what feels right for me. Sometimes it doesn't always work out the way that we want it. You can be absolutely sure of your decision and life can still throw you curveballs. And a big one that I think a lot of us in our early 20s in particular don't think about is fertility, not just like the biological clock, but also kind of, I whether we're able to even have kids, the state of all those other systems. This is just not something that we think about when we are 20 or 21.|||你的社交准备，你关系的牢固程度，你处于一段恋爱关系中，你们俩都准备好要孩子了，你知道的，你一直在想：“是的，我要在20多岁时开始。我要，这就是我想要的，我想成为年轻的父母。这正是我所认为对的选择。”有时事情并不总是按照我们想要的方式发展。你可能对自己的决定百分之百确定，但生活依然会给你抛出难题。我认为我们中的许多人，特别是20出头的人，往往不会去考虑的一个大问题是生育能力，不仅仅是生物钟，还有诸如我们是否甚至有能力生孩子、所有其他系统的状态等等。这根本不是我们在20岁或21岁时会去思考的事情。
But the older you get, you start to hear stories. One of the stories, well, something that I was, it's not a story. It's somebody's, you know, lived experience. The experiences of a friend of mine who, I think, really woke me up to this a couple of years ago, she started having like these really weird symptoms and problems with like her period and with other things and she went to the doctor and i'm not going to disclose exactly what she had what happened but basically they said to her that her chances of having like a natural pregnancy were incredibly low and that if she and her partner wanted to have kids they had to kind of start trying before she was like
But the older you get, you start to hear stories. One of the stories, well, something that I was, it's not a story. It's somebody's, you know, lived experience. The experiences of a friend of mine who, I think, really woke me up to this a couple of years ago, she started having like these really weird symptoms and problems with like her period and with other things and she went to the doctor and i'm not going to disclose exactly what she had what happened but basically they said to her that her chances of having like a natural pregnancy were incredibly low and that if she and her partner wanted to have kids they had to kind of start trying before she was like|||但随着年龄的增长，你开始听到一些故事。其中一个故事，嗯，我所经历的，这不是一个故事。这是某人，你知道的，真实的生活经验。我一个朋友的经历，我认为，几年前真的把我给敲醒了，她开始出现一些非常奇怪的症状，比如她的月经和其他方面出现了问题，她去了医生那里，我不会透露她具体得了什么病发生了什么，但基本上医生对她说，她自然怀孕几率低得惊人，如果她和她的伴侣想要孩子，他们必须在她大概……之前就开始尝试。
28, 29. Like, she had to kind of get a wriggle on. That was essentially what the doctor suggested. This was such a wake-up call for her and for, I would say, the people around her as well, where we were kind of all in this, like, bubble of like, yeah, let's just like fuck around and find out. Like, we're having fun. We're focused on, like, graduating uni and like, yay, like dating around and, like, partying. And then it was suddenly like, oh, wait. I, I just, actually, you know, I think about my future only is my career, and I think about my future only as like, oh, meeting the love of my life and like getting ahead and like buying a house, but it's like, no, there is a part of this that is happening right now, my fertility, that I hadn't even
28, 29. Like, she had to kind of get a wriggle on. That was essentially what the doctor suggested. This was such a wake-up call for her and for, I would say, the people around her as well, where we were kind of all in this, like, bubble of like, yeah, let's just like fuck around and find out. Like, we're having fun. We're focused on, like, graduating uni and like, yay, like dating around and, like, partying. And then it was suddenly like, oh, wait. I, I just, actually, you know, I think about my future only is my career, and I think about my future only as like, oh, meeting the love of my life and like getting ahead and like buying a house, but it's like, no, there is a part of this that is happening right now, my fertility, that I hadn't even|||28、29岁。也就是说，她得抓紧时间了。这基本上就是医生的建议。这给她以及，我想说，她周围的人都敲响了警钟，当时我们都处于这样一种泡沫中，觉得“好吧，让我们尽情玩乐，拭目以待吧”。就像，我们玩得很开心。我们专注于从大学毕业，然后太棒了，到处约会，开派对。然后突然之间就像是，哦，等等。我，我只是，实际上，你知道的，我只把我的未来想成是我的职业生涯，我只把我的未来想成是，哦，遇到我一生的挚爱，然后出人头地，买栋房子，但事实是，不，这其中有一部分正在当下发生，那就是我的生育能力，而我甚至都没有……
considered. And it really raised the question of, is it better to be prepared now or to live in blissful ignorance? Is it worth bursting the bubble of not knowing and almost immediately fast-forward your timeline if you do find out the news that she found out, which is that it might actually end up being really hard if she doesn't start now. Or is it just like better to just get to that problem when you get to it? Here's the thing. If you've always known that you want to be a parent and that is a huge facet of your identity and your goals and your future, I do think that it's worth just knowing in your 20s if that is something that is possible for you. Even if you don't feel responsible yet, knowledge is power, especially as all the science starts to improve. There was this episode of New Girl
considered. And it really raised the question of, is it better to be prepared now or to live in blissful ignorance? Is it worth bursting the bubble of not knowing and almost immediately fast-forward your timeline if you do find out the news that she found out, which is that it might actually end up being really hard if she doesn't start now. Or is it just like better to just get to that problem when you get to it? Here's the thing. If you've always known that you want to be a parent and that is a huge facet of your identity and your goals and your future, I do think that's worth just knowing in your 20s if that is something that is possible for you. Even if you don't feel responsible yet, knowledge is power, especially as all the science starts to improve. There was this episode of New Girl|||考虑过。这确实引发了一个问题：是现在就做好准备比较好，还是活在幸福的无知中比较好？如果得知了她所听到的消息——即如果不从现在开始，结果可能会非常艰难——是否值得戳破无知觉的泡沫，几乎立刻快进你的时间线？或者，这就像是船到桥头自然直，遇到问题再去解决更好？事情是这样的。如果你一直都知道自己想成为父母，并且那是你身份、目标和未来中非常巨大的一部分，我确实认为在20多岁时弄清楚这是否对你可行是值得的。即使你现在还不觉得自己承担得起责任，知识就是力量，尤其是随着所有科学技术的不断进步。有一集《杰茜驾到》（New Girl）
that I watched a while back in which if you've watched New Girl, like, Cece goes in and like, Jess and Cece go in and they assess like their ability to have children. And it's like meant to be this fun thing, you know, like, oh, like, goofy, gougar, like, you know, when you like take a pregnancy test and like, you know it's going to be negative and, you know, you see those movies. it ends up positive. Like it was just meant to be, it's very much like that, meant to be like a funny thing. And Cece, it turns out, like, has very poor fertility and is like really unable, we'll be unable to like conceive naturally. And in that scene, she kind of talks about wishing that she had a magical wand to like go back to early 20s and like tell herself, like, be a little
that I watched a while back in which if you've watched New Girl, like, Cece goes in and like, Jess and Cece go in and they assess like their ability to have children. And it's like meant to be this fun thing, you know, like, oh, like, goofy, gougar, like, you know, when you like take a pregnancy test and like, you know it's going to be negative and, you know, see those movies. it ends up positive. Like it was just meant to be, it's very much like that, meant to be like a funny thing. And Cece, it turns out, like, has very poor fertility and is like really unable, we'll be unable to like conceive naturally. And in that scene, she kind of talks about wishing that she had a magical wand to like go back to early 20s and like tell herself, like, be a little|||我前段时间看过，如果你看过《杰茜驾到》，希茜去检查了生育能力，杰茜和希茜一起去评估她们生孩子的能力。这本该是一件很有趣的事情，你知道的，就像，哦，傻里傻气地，就像，你知道的，当你做验孕棒测试时，你明明知道结果会是阴性的，你知道的，看那些电影。结果却是阳性的。就像这是命中注定的一样，非常像那样，本该是一件有趣的事。结果证明，希茜的生育能力很差，简直无法、将无法自然受孕。在那场戏里，她谈到希望自己有一根魔杖可以回到20多岁出头的时候，告诉自己，要稍微……
bit more serious. So even if it does seem weird to be thinking about it now and even if it does seem pretty intense, intense. I think especially if you're a woman, see, you know, see this questioning around your fertility and your future capacity or desire to have children as an investment in your health. The same way that you want to live a long, healthy life, the same way that you want to have a really successful career. And so you are making investments in that right now. If you do want kids, it's important to be thinking about it sooner, rather than that. later. And I think what I began to realize was that the pressure doesn't increase, but is reduced by being able to make future decisions with full information that might actually derive from a
bit more serious. So even if it does seem weird to be thinking about it now and even if it does seem pretty intense, intense. I think especially if you're a woman, see, you know, see this questioning around your fertility and your future capacity or desire to have children as an investment in your health. The same way that you want to live a long, healthy life, the same way that you want to have a really successful career. And so you are making investments in that right now. If you do want kids, it's important to be thinking about it sooner, rather than that. later. And I think what I began to realize was that the pressure doesn't increase, but is reduced by being able to make future decisions with full information that might actually derive from a|||严肃一点。所以，即使现在去思考这个问题看起来很奇怪，即使它看起来相当激烈、激烈。我认为，特别是如果你是个女性，看吧，你知道的，将这种关于你的生育能力以及你未来生育孩子的能力或愿望的质疑，看作是对你健康的一种投资。就像你希望过上长寿健康的生活一样，就像你希望拥有一个非常成功的事业一样。所以你现在正在为此进行投资。如果你确实想要孩子，早点考虑这一点很重要，总比以后再想要强。而且我认为我开始意识到的是，压力并没有增加，反而通过能够根据充分的信息做出未来的决定而减轻了，这些决定实际上可能源于一个……
decision that you make right now. That is kind of like the appeal of egg freezing, right? Like, I've been reading so much stuff about egg freezing recently. The premise is that you kind of store your good DNA from when you're like in your early mid 30, 20s, sorry, for like later. When you're in like, your 30s or maybe even your 40s, so that it's kind of like insurance. You have time. You can delay the inevitable. It brings control back into the situation. Even if you end up not using those eggs, even if it's not something that you end up
decision that you make right now. That is kind of like the appeal of egg freezing, right? Like, I've been reading so much stuff about egg freezing recently. The premise is that you kind of store your good DNA from when you're like in your early mid 30, 20s, sorry, for like later. When you're in like, your 30s or maybe even your 40s, so that it's kind of like insurance. You have time. You can delay the inevitable. It brings control back into the situation. Even if you end up not using those eggs, even if it's not something that you end up|||你现在做出的决定。这有点像冷冻卵子的吸引力，对吧？比如，我最近读了很多关于冷冻卵子的文章。其前提是，你把30岁出头到中期、20岁出头的优秀DNA储存起来，抱歉，留到以后用。当你处于30多岁甚至40多岁时，这就好比是一份保险。你有时间。你可以推迟不可避免的事情。它将控制权重新带回了局面。即使你最终没有使用那些卵子，即使这不是你最终……
deciding actually know, like, I don't want kids. Like, the climate crisis is too terrible. I just never met the right person. Like, I'm happy without them. It is the sense that, like, the decisions you make now give you the freedom in the future. It's like science has allowed us to control something we were never able to control before, which is time and biology. So that is kind of my argument for why I think it's important to firstly consider whether you even want kids in your 20s. And not in your 20s, like in your 20s consider whether you want kids in the future.
deciding actually know, like, I don't want kids. Like, the climate crisis is too terrible. I just never met the right person. Like, I'm happy without them. It is the sense that, like, the decisions you make now give you the freedom in the future. It's like science has allowed us to control something we were never able to control before, which is time and biology. So that is kind of my argument for why I think it's important to firstly consider whether you even want kids in your 20s. And not in your 20s, like in your 20s consider whether you want kids in the future.|||决定其实并不是这样的，你知道的，就像，“我其实不想要孩子。气候危机太可怕了。我只是从来没有遇到合适的人。我没有他们也很高兴。”这种感觉就像是，你现在做出的决定会给你未来的自由。这就好比科学让我们能够控制以前从未能够控制的东西，那就是时间和生物学。这就是我为什么认为首先要在20多岁时考虑你是否想要孩子的重要性的论点。不是在20多岁生孩子，而是在20多岁时考虑你未来是否想要孩子。
That's probably a better way to put it because the decisions that you make around your health and your fertility now may actually come back to help you. when you do decide in your 30s or 40s. And if you don't want kids, like, great, then you can, you know, start making a plan to live your life more the way that you want it to. And I think the other component is like, it's also important to think about whether you do want to have kids in your 20s, right? Whether like this is a better time, whether, like my friend's example, the knowledge that maybe it will get harder as you age and the older that you get, it's better to start in this moment. So I also wanted to hear from you guys, people who chose to have kids in their 20s, what they would want us to know, whether you're just considering, whether you're decided, or you're acting on it.
That's probably a better way to put it because the decisions that you make around your health and your fertility now may actually come back to help you. when you do decide in your 30s or 40s. And if you don't want kids, like, great, then you can, you know, start making a plan to live your life more the way that you want it to. And I think the other component is like, it's also important to think about whether you do want to have kids in your 20s, right? Whether like this is a better time, whether, like my friend's example, the knowledge that maybe it will get harder as you age and the older that you get, it's better to start in this moment. So I also wanted to hear from you guys, people who chose to have kids in their 20s, what they would want us to know, whether you're just considering, whether you've decided, or you're acting on it.|||这样说可能更贴切，因为你现在围绕健康和生育能力所做的决定，将来在你30多岁或40多岁决定要孩子时，实际上可能会反过来帮到你。如果你不想要孩子，那太好了，然后你就可以，你知道的，开始制定计划，按照你想要的方式过上更多的生活。我认为另一个部分是，思考你是否确实想在20多岁时要孩子也很重要，对吧？比如这是否是更好的时机，就像我朋友的例子那样，得知随着年龄的增长事情可能会变得更难，而且越老越难，最好现在就开始。所以我也想听听你们大家的意见，那些选择在20多岁生孩子的人，他们希望我们了解什么，无论你只是在考虑，还是已经做出了决定，或者正在付诸行动。
Stay with us for more after the break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
Stay with us for more after the break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.|||休息之后，请继续收听更多精彩内容。2%. 这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越充斥着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。世界上令我们惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.|||让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听TWO%。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here. unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here. unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,|||我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份。剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.|||大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，对84年我印象深刻，不仅仅是因为快克。我可以一整天都在聊快克，但为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿的线索了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for Black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
I don't think there's a more important year for Black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase|||我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person|||以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们盯着记分牌，生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得做一个好人很重要
while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.|||当你在世时，还是你因为恐惧才成为一个好人？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟，完全如此，那是两个不同级别的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，《单身汉》前明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.|||随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出她故事中惊人的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.|||还有两个男人经历过同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.|||女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一，绝不要惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid games. surprises. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
You play stupid games, you get stupid games. surprises. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.|||玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的惊喜。法则二，也绝不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这一季全新的《The Girlfriends》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There is obviously a perspective to this that I can't bring. I don't have kids, and as much as, you know, I was speaking about this weird maternal urge that suddenly popped up out of nowhere in the last year.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There is obviously a perspective to this that I can't bring. I don't have kids, and as much as, you know, I was speaking about this weird maternal urge that suddenly popped up out of nowhere in the last year.|||在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。显然，对于这件事，我有一个无法企及的视角。我没有孩子，尽管，你知道的，我刚才谈到了过去一年里不知从哪突然冒出来的这种奇怪的母性冲动。
I really don't plan on it for the next, like, five to ten years. But I wanted to hear from people who, have thought about it a lot, especially people in their 20s who have decided to have children, perhaps earlier than what most of us would expect in this day and age, or people who have had to make big decisions about fertility in their 20s that feel really adult and feel like they are something that should have, you know, that they could have delayed but then couldn't. So I saw this actually really funny article before I read this first thing, that having children in your 20s is now like punk.
I really don't plan on it for the next, like, five to ten years. But I wanted to hear from people who, have thought about it a lot, especially people in their 20s who have decided to have children, perhaps earlier than what most of us would expect in this day and age, or people who have had to make big decisions about fertility in their 20s that feel really adult and feel like they are something that should have, you know, that they could have delayed but then couldn't. So I saw this actually really funny article before I read this first thing, that having children in your 20s is now like punk.|||在未来的五到十年里，我真的不打算这么做。但我很想听听那些思考过这个问题的人的看法，特别是那些20多岁、决定要孩子的人，也许比我们大多数人在当今时代所预期的要早，或者那些在20多岁时不得不做出关于生育的重大决定的人，这些决定让人感觉非常成熟，感觉就像是他们本应该……你知道的，他们本可以推迟但后来却无法推迟的事情。所以在阅读第一部分之前，我实际上看到了一篇非常有趣的文章，上面说在20多岁时生孩子现在就像朋克一样。
which is so funny and that's kind of like you know what I do I kind of get it because yet again when I hear about people having kids in their 20s it's not that I feel any certain way about it I'm just like oh that's different when actually it's not really it's not so I do want to hear about it I do want to hear from people about it about their decision their timeline when they started thinking about things and their fears so here is the first person that messaged us and I really love her perspective. I always knew I wanted to be a parent and had my baby girl at 23. I faced a lot of stigma that she was an accident.
这太有趣了，这有点像——你知道我做的——我有点理解，因为再次听到有人在20多岁时生孩子时，倒不是说我对它有什么特定的看法，我只是觉得“哦，这挺特别”，而实际上又并非如此，这其实很正常。所以我确实想听听这方面的内容，我想听听人们关于这件事的看法、他们的决定、时间表、什么时候开始考虑这些事情以及他们的恐惧。所以，这是第一个给我们发信息的人，我真的很喜欢她的视角。我一直都知道自己想成为父母，并在23岁时生下了我的宝贝女儿。我面临了很多污名化，认为她是个意外。
Oh my God, sidebar. Why would you ever say that to somebody? That is so freaking rude. Anyhow, back to this person. I would face stigma that she was an accident when actually I'd been together with my now husband since we were 18 and it was part of our plan. I still lost friends who didn't get it and had people judge me,
天哪，顺便说一句。为什么有人会对别人说那种话？这太无礼了。不管怎样，回到这个人身上。我会面临她是意外的污名化，而实际上我和现在的老公从18岁起就在一起了，这是我们计划的一部分。我甚至失去了那些不理解的朋友，还有人对我说三道四，
but she is now five, and I like knowing that she was. would be 20 when I'm 43 and I can be a young parent as she grows up and keep up with her. See, that is the kind of perspective that I think we don't hear too often. People who, you know, had kids young and how that is actually like a really valuable thing for them. I think a lot of the time, and I will speak for myself here, you see people who have had children young and you're like, well, that's a bit different.
但她现在五岁了，我喜欢这样的事实：当我43岁时她将是20岁，随着她长大，我可以做一个年轻的父母并跟上她的步伐。你看，这就是那种我认为我们不常听到的观点。那些在年轻时生孩子的人，以及这如何对他们来说实际上是一件非常有价值的事情。我想很多时候，我在这里也代表我自己，你会看到那些年轻时生过孩子的人，然后你会觉得，“嗯，那有点不一样”。
And you think about what they might be missing out because that wouldn't be your choice. but as this person said, like, no, she didn't, yes, she may have missed out in the sense that she lost friends that sound like they were never really her friends, but she gained so much. And I think when you are clear that that is going to be part of your plan, and when you have really considered it and thought about it, you can actually choose when it's going to work best for you. And for her, it sounded like when she was younger, that was really what was aligned with how she wanted to raise her child and she's doing it. So I really liked that input.
你会想他们可能会错过什么，因为那不会是你的选择。但正如这个人所说，不，她没有——是的，她可能在失去朋友的意义上错过了什么，那些朋友听起来从来都不是真正的朋友，但她收获了太多。我想，当你明确这会成为你计划的一部分，当你真正考虑过并思考过它时，你实际上可以自主选择什么时候它对你来说效果最好。对她来说，听起来当她更年轻时，那确实与她想要抚养孩子的方式相契合，而且她正在这样做。所以我真的很喜欢这个反馈。
I thought that was really a perspective, a side of things that we don't always hear. Here is another person who wrote in. I found out that I had half a uterus when I was 21, and that just put everything into perspective then and there. It felt like I aged out of my friend group immediately, and no one could understand how my life felt different because suddenly I was thinking about decisions they didn't have to make for years. Whoa.
我认为这确实是一个观点，是我们并不总能听到的事情的一面。这里是另一个人写信的内容。我在21岁时发现自己只有一个半子宫，从那一刻起，这让一切都有了不一样的视角。我觉得自己立刻就从我的朋友圈子里“超龄”了，没有人能理解为什么我的生活感觉不同了，因为突然之间我在考虑那些他们多年都不需要做出的决定。哇。
That was three years ago. still don't have a partner, but I feel more at peace with the fact that I'll be okay if it doesn't work out because I had time and more time to consider whether this was even for me. I'm glad I got to be okay with what could happen and not be really excited about it when I was 30 and married, then find out the hard way. Yes, it was hard, but now I know more about my values and priorities than I did before I found out about my uterus. Why did I say it like that? My uterus.
那是三年前的事了。我仍然没有伴侣，但我对这件事感到更加平静：即使事情没有成功我也没关系，因为我有时间、有更多的时间来考虑这是否真的适合我。我很高兴我能坦然接受可能发生的事情，而不是在30岁结婚时对此感到无比兴奋，然后才以艰难的方式发现真相。是的，这很难，但现在我比知道我的子宫状况之前更清楚自己的价值观和优先级了。我为什么会那样说？我的子宫。
Thank you. Thank you for sharing. It really comes back to that point. You know, kids aren't everything at the end of the day. You don't need to reproduce to have a purpose. But maybe to paraphrase what you're saying, it seems like at the end of the day, it's about having choice.
谢谢。谢谢你的分享。这真的回到了那个观点。你知道，归根结底，孩子并不是全部。你不需要繁衍后代来获得人生目标。但也许用你所说的话来释义，归根结底，这似乎是关于拥有选择权。
That's what feels meaningful here. And choice also comes from knowledge. And knowing more in your 20s, even if it might up the stakes actually lets you have time to consider things and to consider what you want in the long term and the alternatives to that ultimate choice. Let's hear from one more person. Hi, I'm so glad that you were talking about this because I feel like it is so weird amongst my group when I bring this up.
这才是这里感觉有意义的地方。而选择也来自于知识。在20多岁时了解更多，即使它可能会提高赌注，实际上也能让你有时间考虑事情，并考虑你在长期内想要什么以及最终选择的替代方案。让我们听听另一个人的意见。嗨，我很高兴你们在谈论这个，因为当我提起这个时，我觉得在我的朋友圈子里这太奇怪了。
People want to stay young, thinking about kids feels old. I made the decision to freeze my eggs through work because I am 28. I have a boyfriend slash life partner but we haven't decided whether we want to have children yet, although we have definitely thought about it. Egg freezing just took the stress away and work paid for it. For people thinking about it, it does put a lot of strain on your body and it's costly, so know that going in. Some part of me thought that if I went through that, I must know that I want kids because otherwise,
人们想要保持年轻，想到孩子就觉得老了。我通过公司做出了冷冻卵子的决定，因为我28岁。我有一个男朋友兼生活伴侣，但我们还没有决定是否要生孩子，尽管我们确实考虑过。冷冻卵子只是消除了压力，而且公司为此付了钱。对于正在考虑的人来说，这确实对你的身体造成了很大的压力，而且成本很高，所以在决定之前要了解这一点。我有一部分心想，如果我经历了这一切，我一定知道我想要孩子，否则，
why would I do it? yes, it is important to think about kids in your 20s as a hypothetical, but I want to stress that you do not, I want to stress that you do have more time than you think. My mom had me at 38 back then she was so old. She told me she was never worried about it though because she loved, she loved her life and she would have had a full and wonderful life whether I came around or not and I love that philosophy. It is a big decision, but you can wait until you were 38 or older and still be successful. Okay, sorry, I feel like I really fell over my words there. I really love this point, and I think this is a really good one to end on, though, because it brings some nuance. As this person said, you know, she still made a huge decision about her fertility, and she didn't know, but you do have time. Kids aren't everything.
我为什么要这样做？是的，把20多岁时考虑孩子作为一个假设是很重要的，但我想要强调的是，你确实——我想要强调的是，你确实比你想象的要有更多的时间。我妈妈在38岁时生了我，在当时她太老了。不过她告诉我她从不为此担心，因为她热爱她的生活，无论我是否出现，她都会拥有充实而精彩的生活，我喜欢这种哲学。这是一个重大的决定，但你可以等到38岁或更大年纪，依然可以成功。好的，抱歉，我觉得我刚才真的语无伦次了。不过，我真的很喜欢这个观点，我认为这是一个很好的收尾观点，因为它带来了一些细微差别。正如这个人所说，你知道，她仍然做出了关于她生育能力的重大决定，她并不知道结果，但你确实有时间。孩子不是全部。
You can change your mind. You can start late. And I think it's a good way to finish this up is to really articulate and express that science is coming a long way. Like this episode was not to sit down and stress us all out about, you know, go and get a scan right now, go and find out if you can have kids like start on your family planning journey as young as possible because that does sound very like the handmade's tale. I understand it. but I think that the whole philosophy that underlies this whole episode is that more information equals more choice. And if we think about retirement in our 20s, if we think about our dream jobs in our 20s, if we think about finding the love of our life in our 20s, all these big things,
你可以改变主意。你可以晚点开始。我认为结束这个话题的一个好方法是真正清晰地表达和阐述科学已经取得了长足的进步。就像这一集不是为了让我们所有人都坐在这里，为诸如“快去查个体检，快去看看你能不能生孩子，尽早开始你的家庭规划之旅”之类的事情感到焦虑，因为那听起来真的很像《使女的故事》。我理解这一点。但我认为支撑这一整集的整个哲学是：更多的信息等于更多的选择。如果我们把20多岁时的退休规划、20多岁时的梦想工作、20多岁时寻找一生挚爱放在心上，所有这些大事，
right? We should, you know, all these big things that are the ingredients for our life plan and are the ingredients for our 5 and 10 year plan. We should also be thinking about children. And if you don't want them, that is honestly so, like, I don't feel like I need to say that. But yes, just stress it one more time. If you don't want them, great. Like, you come to that decision, you come to that conclusion. And yes, you can change your mind. But it's also, like, if you do want kids, there are factors that are important to consider during this decade,
对吧？我们应该——你知道，所有这些构成我们生活计划和5年、10年计划要素的大事。我们也应该考虑孩子。如果你不想要孩子，老实说这非常——就像，我觉得我不需要说这个。但是是的，再强调一次。如果你不想要孩子，那很好。比如，你做出了那个决定，你得出了那个结论。是的，你可以改变主意。但同时，如果你确实想要孩子，在这个十年里有一些因素是需要考虑的，
whether that is your dating choices, whether that is your health, that we have more power by thinking about earlier. So I do hope that this episode has made you think or has just been entertaining, has helped you learn something. Thank you so much to the people who wrote in with their perspectives and their life experience. It was just something really that I've been thinking about a lot and I was interested to talk about. I would love to hear what you guys think. If you have a story, if you have an opinion, something else that you want to say, please DM me on Instagram at That Psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you. And if there's somebody else who you think would be interested in this episode who wants to hear it, please feel free to send it to them.
无论是你的约会选择，还是你的健康状况，通过更早地思考这些，我们拥有了更多的力量。所以我确实希望这一集能引发你的思考，或者只是具有娱乐性，帮你学到一些东西。非常感谢那些写信分享观点和生活经验的人们。这真的只是我一直在思考很多而且有兴趣谈论的话题。我很想听听你们的想法。如果你有一个故事、一个观点、或者其他想说的话，请在Instagram上私信我：That Psychology podcast。我很期待听到你们的声音。如果你觉得还有其他人会对这一集感兴趣并想听听，请随时分享给他们。
Make sure you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now and that you're following along for future episodes. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind and be gentle to yourself. And we'll talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
确保你在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，并且关注未来的节目。直到下次，保持安全。对自己好一点，温柔一点。我们很快再聊。2%。这就是电梯旁边也有自动扶梯时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness. fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app,
我是我的播客《2%》的主持人。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，精神坚韧、健身和培养韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用上的TWA%，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
Apple Podcasts，或者你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的
experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行的。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了测试一次。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a Love Trapped podcast on the Eyehorpe. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在Eyehorpe收听《Love Trapped》播客。Heart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜们。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你。获取播客的地方。这是一个IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证纯人工。本集暂无评论。点击转录文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。